our next guest you know him as the
marvelous mrs maisel mr joel mazel yeah
that's right that's michael zeegan he's
here
and the marvelous mrs maisel is back
with a brand new season and we have got
a sneak peek for you
check it out
you know joel i still consider you a
family member and it seems a shame that
you're alone that was a perfectly good
girl i set him up with last week lena
brothman it was a boy by the way wow you
were quick excuse me ma for not wanting
to go out with a pregnant divorced woman
she's not divorced her husband died
everyone dies can we chase a
subject get your butt out here
[Music]
[Applause]
and i made a movie together um called
the stand-in
and it's the weirdest movie and i played
two people and i think i did have kind
of a mental nervous breakdown doing it
and i got to do it all in the presence
and uh
joy of your company yeah but it was
great i had i had a great time doing it
and we had a great time in kentucky
we really did yeah you were great to me
it was i we were we i felt like i went
through a very bizarre unique experience
with you and i'm so closer to for it but
you know sometimes people get mad at you
right like do they get mad at you on the
street because they have such an opinion
about how joel is supposed to behave um
they used to but uh but yeah no uh these
days they're nice they you know i think
joel has evolved as a character and uh
it was it was kind of unfair because in
the first season in the first episode
especially he he leaves this this
perfect woman and uh and people didn't
forgive me for that you know he cheated
on her too so so it was it was yeah it
was double bad right okay so
we talked about this before but i want
to talk about here you played dwight the
troubled teen on letterman yeah you were
how old
oh i mean i was not a teen uh i was i
was 22 i think okay but you looked like
a team yeah yeah i think they might have
thought that i was a teen though i think
i i tricked them and letterman loved you
and said bring this back and it became a
reoccurring thing
yes yes i
okay
you also
were in the sopranos i mean i love that
the current most popular show mazel
you're on but like letterman sopranos
please just give us a fly on the wall
moment of being on the sopranos
uh
yeah i mean
it was a long time ago but everybody was
super nice it was it was a party scene i
got to to fight uh with some other kid
and and like i remember
in the script it didn't say who won so
we were each like really trying and
because you know didn't want to look bad
didn't look like uh want to look like a
wuss um yeah yeah and you're on the
sopranos i know but i've gone for it but
yeah i mean that that kind of started
the trend i also did the walking dead i
did girls at boardwalk empire these
shows that i like was watching
yeah i'm not
i'm not like
tooting my own horn or anything you're
just saying there's a pattern okay so
what happens if you like you know
start watching a scary documentary about
some serial killer are you going to end
up i've been doing that actually really
yeah
yeah but yeah no i'm obsessed with i
think we probably talked about that
i'm obsessed with uh serial killer
documentaries not serial killers in
general
[Music]